garde
discute à aller jouer dans mes bras
bisous
pour sa collègue
mais si je
suis tu sais j'ai un prénom et ton grand
frère ce genre tu me fais un bisou
ouais
alors alors alors terminé quand je suis
comme ça alors alors elle répète après
moi je vous écris tu as faits mais c'est
un témoin mathieu c'était un petit peu
trop loin
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas derrière toi non
alors je le dis je déteste en plus comme
mathieu n'est pas bien parce que je
l'aimais vraiment pas comme vous tous
d'ailleurs et c'est vrai que je vous dis
les choses parce que je vous aime et tu
sais que je ne m'entends pas toi bon je
vais en parler à laurent fontaine qui
est un ami en plus laurent et voilà je
peux donner mon avis oui sans doute mais
tu sais que toi en fait parce que tu vas
les mangas mais parfois oui je suis
l'ami tellement mais non mais parce que
moi je vais te dire où je vois pas de
mal c'est mon chéri je vois pas de mal
je dis tout parce que bon on est on est
familier on est une famille et que les
téléspecteurs je te le jure c'est vrai
et je dis les choses de la série et que
je franchement je ne voulais pas du tout
est vexé je te le jure alors peut-être
j'étais un petit peu loin à bras parce
que
[Applaudissements]
désir
parce que et me fais je vous dis la
vérité et il me connaître je n'aime
tellement il me fait de la peine et je
laime parce qu'en plus je n'étais pas
contre toi je te trouve extraordinaire
jeudi il joue il vous dis pas les bonnes
choses que je les appelais deux heures
samedi c'est ça qui m'énerve aussi fait
éteinte et paul ont adressé la
tunisie pas tout et samedi est ce que je
t'ai pas appelé plainte en fait il était
formidable et alors bah voilà et mais en
fait je ne te remets pas en cause je
remets pas en cause si je te donne juste
mon avis c'est pas je te dis jamais je
ne tape pas sur les doigts comme
hachette je te donne mon avis sur la
séquence j'ai le droit de parler aussi
avec mon ami et je le dis devant les
téléspectateurs tu es mon ami voilà donc
je te dis les choses c'est la chose
d'infiniment j'aurais juste aimé parce
que comme forcément moi j'ai des gens
dans ma boîte pour que toi qui
travaillaient sur toi faut que je garde
un peu la tête haute je rentre dans ma
boîte laisser le patronyme qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont me dire tous les gamins tant
que c'est pas trop le malin il ya deux
heures pendant que tu me vois
tu leur dis il leur dit que je suis ton
ami et qu'on se dit les choses c'est
tout et moi je vais pas y aller avec
géraldine agen vérité même si les flics
de temps de jeu juste ça c'est toi tu
m'appelles tu me au téléphone tu me
défonce dans et après fonds publics tu
me défends parce que c'était équipe même
si derrière au fond tu m'as du doigt ce
que j'aurais préféré simple dans l'autre
sens isabey mais je ne t'ai pas
défaussés je te donne mon avis je
défends que je dois défendre aussi
publiquement mon ami et mon ennemi est
mon ami jean marie bigard je te le dis
moi c'est ton chéri tu l'aimés en plus
jean marie mais j'ai rien contre eux
[Rires]
oui mais voilà alors tout n'est pas
rangé parce que il doit de l'oseille
ça alors joris laquelle est arrogé pour
l'instant je parie que dans un instant
et afida turner
[Rires]
mais c'est vrai que je n'ai honnêtement
qui m'a élevé de la bête et je sais
qu'avec est avec moi et je te le dis et
c'est mon défaut aussi et le serons nous
c'est que tu m'aurais dit oui c'est vrai
laurent fontaine est allé loin on est
terminée on aurait fait une rigolade et
c'est vrai que je peux me braquer
[Applaudissements]
le monde
le problème je peux avoir des réactions
disproportionnées
quelqu'un m'a sud c'est vrai que je vois
c'est ça peut ça peut partir vite eu
benjamin le mmm gratuitement
voilà c'est vrai mais mais tu sais comme
je t'aime et tu sais comme je suis fier
de toi voilà et comme pour est un peu
une à valérie qui cartonne et benjamin
aussi mon chéri et comme nicolas
pernikoff à
y revenir